montagnes de billets de banque comme ça
il faut en faire quelque chose l'argent
sale devient très rapidement et très
facilement gris et puis blanc il suffit
de passer par quelques sociétés écrans
mais à côté de ça vous avez tout un
réseau de banques qui sont beaucoup plus
ouverte au cash à l'époque de la crise
de 2008 vous dit même que les banques
qui ont été beaucoup moins regardante
sur la provenance de cet argent qui
arrivaient pour renflouer les caisses ça
a été même dit aux nations unies on a
constaté que plusieurs dizaines de
milliards issus du trafic de stupéfiants
ont été absorbés par un certain nombre
de banques aux états unis qui d'ailleurs
ont été poursuivis en justice et ont
payé des amendes en conséquence
[Musique]
joe biden premier président des états
unis à reconnaître le génocide arménien
c'est le 106e anniversaire de ce
massacre
aujourd'hui à erevan ils sont des
milliers à s'être rassemblés pour rendre
hommage aux victimes plus d'un million
d'arméniens ont été tués par les troupes
de l'empiré ottoman pendant la première
guerre mondiale on en parle dès le début
de ce journal renforcer la sécurité des
commissariats et des gendarmeries c'est
le souhait du ministre de l'intérieur
gérald darmanin après l'assassinât d'une
policière au commissariat de rambouillet
hier une quatrième personne a été placée
en garde à vue dans le cadre de l'
enquête l'assaillant tunisien 36 ans
n'était ni connu de la police ni des
services de renseignement sa famille
décrit un homme dépressif et puis la
junte birmane appelé à cesser les
violences contre les civils et à
rétablir la démocratie déclarations du
président indonésien à l'issue d'une
réunion de crise avec les autres
dirigeants des pays d'asie du sud est le
chef de l'armée birmane était présent et
ne serait pas opposé à ce que
l'association des nations de l'asie du
sud-est joue un rôle constructif plus de
700 personnes sont mortes depuis le coup
d'état du premier
mais
[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez sur rt france il est 20 heures
l'anniversaire du génocide arménien
marquée par une reconnaissance cette
année est celle de joe biden une
reconnaissance dont se réjouit l'arménie
qui rendait aujourd'hui hommage à ces
victimes alors que la turquie elle nie
ce génocide ankara déclare n'avoir de
leçon à recevoir de personne sur son
histoire
le président turc recep tayyip erdogan
dénoncent la politisation du débat
autour du génocide arménien plus d'un
million d'arméniens ont été tués par les
troupes de l'empiré ottoman pendant la
première guerre mondiale à paris
aujourd'hui emmanuel macron a lui aussi
commémoré ce 106e anniversaire il a
parlé du devoir d'empêcher le déni et le
mensonge
les précisions avec notre reporter sur
place d'ali ben khalifa
après une cérémonie officielle à 15
heures où de nombreux élus politiques
étaient à présent parmi eux anne hidalgo
la maire de paris est le porte parole du
gouvernement gabriel attal ou bien
encore là un président de la région
ile-de-france valérie pécresse des
milliers de manifestants ont défilé dans
la rue jusqu'ici place du trocadéro pour
évidemment se souvenir et d un million
cinq cent mille arméniens qui se sont
fait massacrer
lors de la première guerre mondiale par
l'empiré ottoman
mais l'objectif était également de
rappeler que la récidive est possible en
référence notamment au récent conflit
dans le haut karabagh à une défaite
militaire qui a laissé beaucoup de
traces est vécue comme une véritable
humiliation nationale pour la plupart
des hasards magnin et des franco
arménien je vous propose d'écouter
franck papazian coprésident du cca est
fait organisateurs de cette cérémonie de
match cet après midi nous étions avec un
hidalgo la maire de paris valérie
pécresse a président de la région ile de
france
gabriella talent le représentant du
gouvernement le porte parole du
gouvernement
pareil pour exprimer nos revendications
condamné
et la turquie et l'azerbaïdjan qui ont
été complices dans la guerre qui a été
livrée contre les arméniens dans le haut
karabakh une guerre évidemment
condamnable où les ces deux puissances
ont utilisé des drones des armes à sous
munitions des bombes à phosphore blanc
dans le seul but c'est effectivement de
faire partir les arméniens du
haut-karabakh et d'occuper le territoire
est également rappelé à erdogan qu'il
est temps aujourd'hui que la turquie
revisitait son histoire et fassent acte
de reconnaissance et de réparation
la présence d' emmanuel macron devant ce
mémorial parisien en hommage aux
victimes du génocide arménien est un
symbole fort pour la plupart des
manifestants mais pour eux ce n'est pas
suffisant il aurait aimé que la france
réagit ce que la france agisse lors du
dernier conflit dans le haut-karabakh
août enfin on voit bien que là il ya une
volonté de se débarrasser de cet état
chrétien qui demandent rien à personne
que d'être là et de préserver sa culture
et donc on aurait apprécié quand même un
geste plus fort de l'occident chrétien
qui se dit chrétien et la france en
particulier donc on est un peu déçu
quand même de bon le geste les gerbes
les belles paroles c'est bien mais face
aux drones aux missiles et au char c'est
un peu court
clairement aujourd'hui donc ce qu'on
espère c'est que la france au travers du
groupe de minsk s'impliquent aujourd'hui
davantage pour que le haut karabagh sont
un territoire arménien qui est
aujourd'hui une démocratie avec un
président de la république et que les
terres soient restitués à l'arménie en
tant que tel donc si on est là c'est
parce que effectivement il ya un
génocide en 1915 qui s'est poursuivie
jusqu'en 1920 23 mais on est là parce
que ce jeu de sites se poursuit
aujourd'hui
parce que la négation d'un génocide
c'est la poursuite d'un génocide
pour rappel la france a reconnu le
génocide arménien en 2001 une trentaine
de pays est également
une quatrième garde à vue est en cours
dans l' enquête sur l'attaqué mortelle
d'une fonctionnaire de police à
rambouillet hier l'assaillant un
tunisien de 36 ans à être inconnu des
services de renseignement et de la
justice son profil reste floue sa
famille a décrit un homme dépressif
le parquet antiterroriste s'est saisi de
la sphère il s'agit d'éclaircir son
parcours et de connaître les raisons qui
l'ont poussé à commettre cet assassinat
des perquisitions ont eu lieu à son
domicile les trois autres personnes
gardées à vue sont vu renouveler leur
garde à vue un hommage sera rendu à la
police hier lundi devant l'hôtel de
ville de rambouillet est pas la première
fois que des policiers des yvelines sont
visés à magnanville deux fonctionnaires
de police ont été tués par un terroriste
c'était en 2016 et puis plus récemment
en octobre dernier le professeur samuel
pâtit été décapités à conflans sainte
honorine dimitri scission il est 14
heures passées de quelques minutes
quand stéphanie policière de 49 ans et
mère de deux enfants est tué de
plusieurs coups de couteau hier
le meurtre a eu lieu dans le sas
d'entrée du commissariat où elle
travaillait depuis plus de 20 ans
l'assassin présumé un tunisien en
situation régulière a été abattu par les
collègues de la victime
dès la fin de journée l' enquête sur les
motivations et les potentiels
complicités dont a bénéficié
l'assaillant a été confiée au parquet
national anti terroriste les raisons de
cette saisine sont les suivants en
premier le déroulement même des feuilles
qui comprend des éléments de repérage
également réalisation d'effets modalités
veille du crime la personne de la
victime mais aussi les propos tenus par
l'auteur au moment de la réalisation des
feux
présent sur les lieux jean castex a tenu
à inscrire cet acte dans la lignée des
précédents
une nouvelle fois le département des
yvelines est mis à rude épreuve des
attaques terroristes
puisque nous avons tous en mémoire
l'odieux attentat de magnanville en 2016
et plus récemment l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit il y a cinq ans la police des
yvelines était déjà touché en plein
coeur dans leur pavillon de magnanville
jessica schnyder et son mari tous deux
policiers au commissariat des mureaux
mouret poignardé leurs agresseurs
laroussi abdallah islamistes
radicalisées a grandi dans les environs
il sera abattu alors qu'il s'est
retranché dans le pavillon de ses
victimes en octobre dernier à conflans
sainte honorine toujours dans les
yvelines
la décapitation de samuel pâtit secoue
la france toute entière
le professeur a été tué par un exilés
tchétchènes pour avoir montré à ses
élèves les caricatures du prophète
mahomet publiée par charlie hebdo et
pour noël manoir délégué du syndicat
policier vigie il faut renforcer la
vigilance policière et en particulier
les vendredis sous de nombreux attentats
ont déjà été commis écouter ça fait des
années que j'appelle à la vigilance
c'est là que les policiers et les
services de police au niveau du
commandement doivent appeler à la
vigilance sur le mois de ramadhan et en
particulier les journées de vendredi
parce qu'il faut savoir que là on est à
plusieurs dizaines d'attentats qui ont
lieu le vendredi sert plus de 70% des
attentats qui n'était pas écrit depuis
2016 ont été perpétrés le vendredi le
vendredi 13 novembre
le thalys nathan chez elle son capot
poignarder des passants à villejuif
récemment romans sur isère
l'attentât devant les locaux de charlie
hebdo samuel paty et j'en passe c'est à
dire que je peux même plus les compter
ils ont lieu le vendredi à chaque fois
et là j'ai enquêté à mon niveau et
aucune consigne de vigilance n'a été
donnée à la proche du mois de ramadan et
10 du vent de nini dès vendredi en
particulier d'ailleurs
alors qu'un milliard de doses de vaccin
anti qu'ovide ont été administrées dans
le monde depuis aujourd'hui en france on
peut se faire vacciner avec l'américain
johnson de johnson & johnson une dose
suffit avec ce vaccin mais il est
réservé aux plus de 55 ans
c'est le quatrième vaccins administrés
en france l' agence européenne des
médicaments a confirmé la positivité de
sa balance bénéfices risques je vous
rappelle qu'il avait été suspendue après
la découverte aux états unis de carrare
de thrombose bassin chebbi c'est ce
samedi qu'a nouveau vaccin contre le coc
vie 19 fait son entrée en france et peut
contribuer à booster la campagne de
vaccination mais à peine arrivé sur le
sol français voilà que ce vaccin fait
déjà débat si son usage à dose unique
est une première dans cette campagne de
vaccination son efficacité elle est
sujette à certaines des réticences mais
alors que savons nous réellement de ce
vaccin déjà utilisée aux états unis est
confronté à de réels suspicions d'effets
secondaires
à l'heure actuelle quelques deux cent
mille doses de vaccin johnson & johnson
ont déjà été livrées en france destiné
aux plus de 55 ans il pourra être
administrée par les infirmiers libéraux
par les médecins mais aussi par les
formations
nous attendons le vaccin nous avons fait
la demande
comme indiqué par la dgs et nous
espérons le recevoir dans les jours qui
viennent
comment va se passer de livraison de ce
fameux vaccin est prévu pour pour
l'instant vu les indications qu'on a
eues la semaine dernière commande et un
flacon par semaine livrables la semaine
suivante
donc on n'est pas livré dans la même
semaine ensuite moi n'étant pas
titulaire de l'officine j'ai quand même
mon diplôme de pharmacien engagé j'ai
décidé dans l'exercice de ma profession
de ne vacciner que des gens pour
lesquels je peux accéder à leur dossier
on a des patients intéressés parce qu'il
ya une seule injection est ce qui est
beaucoup plus pratique et beaucoup n'ont
plus motivant à la vaccination
il n'y a pas d'écart trop importants
comme il y en a avec astrazeneca
je ne veux pas prendre le risque de
vacciner des gens qui ont des
traitements chroniques
type anticoagulant type diabète type que
je ne connais pas donc je veux qu'il ya
un état de confiance entre le patient et
moi dans l'acte vaccinal vos patients
que j'ai sélectionné son courant des
effets secondaires qui ont été annoncées
sont au courant parce que c'est mon rôle
de leur indiquer il y à un risque vous
le savez je vous explique
et après c'est à moi de leur donner
confiance et d'être dans la pédagogie
son efficacité si l'on s'en réfère aux
dires du fabricant américain il serait
efficace à 80% il grimperait même à 100%
contre les hospitalisations et décès de
quoi être rassuré serait même
respectivement efficace de 81 et 87 %
contre les variants sud africain et
brésilien
alors vous l'aurez compris ce vaccin
pourrait être la star des sérums
détrônant ceux des laboratoires pfizer
modern ans ou encore astrazeneca
mais tout cela c'est sans compter les
nombreux effets secondaires révélé sur
des dizaines de patients aux états unis
outre atlantique en effet une dizaine de
cas de thrombose cérébrale rares ont été
observés autrement dit des caillots
sanguins ce qui a valu au géant de
l'industrie pharmaceutique d'être dans
le viseur des autorités sanitaires
malgré un scénario qui rappelle à s'y
méprendre celui de l'astra zeneca dont
l'utilisation avait été stoppée par de
nombreux pays
l'agencé européenne des médicaments a
toutefois recommandé sa livraison et son
utilisation
jugeant la balance bénéfice-risque
largement favorable aux patients paris
devrait recevoir jusqu'à 8 millions de
doses d'ici la fin du mois de juin de
quoi accélérer la campagne de
vaccination sur l'ensemble du territoire
malgré des doutes persistants qui risque
encore de ralentir la campagne de
vaccination manifestation à toulon place
de l'opéra une centaine de personnes se
sont rassemblées cet après midi pour
contester les décisions gouvernementales
politique sanitaire jugé dictatorial ou
à sécurité globale qualifiée de
liberticide ou encore une situation
difficile pour les intermittents du
spectacle de nombreux artistes étaient
justement sur place
on demande aussi des droits sociaux pour
tous dire que nous intermittent on a eu
une année blanche nous a permis de
patienter et de pouvoir être soutenu
pendant cette année où on devait
retravailler
on n'a pas pu retravailler de façon
égale tous ceux qui étaient dans le
spectacle vivant n'ont pratiquement pas
pu retravailler tout ce qui était plus
dans l'audiovisuel ont pu un peu
retravaillé
donc ils n'ont rien il nous a pu cotiser
ils n'ont pas pu être pays ils ont été
soutenus par ron farha effectivement
l'unedic mais les caisses sont vides
qu'on est contre ces lois liberticides
voilà les lois qui sépare qui stigmatise
les gens voient là un et qui font pas
sociétés qui font pas commun voilà donc
on est contre s'ils viennent nous
entraver notre liberté
plein de domaines où la liberté les
libertés se réduisent
tu vois là en fait la perçoit que le
temps passant avait fait du tout
confiance à ceux qui nous gouvernent à
ceux qui sont censés nous soigner
j'avais envie de le dire le pastorat
finale pour moi c'est une seule entrave
à la liberté
c'est une façon déguisée de d'obliger
les gens à vacciner pour qu'ils puissent
a priori fonctionner comme d'habitude
quarantaine depuis aujourd'hui pour les
voyageurs provenant de certaines
destinations les pays concernés sont
l'inde le brésil le chili ou encore
l'afrique du sud
à leur arrivée les voyageurs qui peuvent
entrer sur le territoire français se
voit imposer une mise à l'isolément de
10 jours en cause une circulation du
virus particulièrement inquiétante dans
ces pays
nos équipes sont allées à la rencontre
des voyageurs à l'aéroport charles de
gaulle
non je pensais c'est très bien pour la
santé de tout le monde et je trouve ces
nouvelles sections qu'ils ont mis en
mesure sont très bien pour tous les pays
et la quarantaine pour les personnes
qu'ils ont attrapé le virus
je pense que c'est très bien de les
mettre en quarantaine pour avoir moins
de cas surtout en france en turquie
partout dans tous les pays et je trouve
ça très très bien même si on n'est pas
positif il faut il faut rester il faut
s'isoler a pour dix jours chez nous donc
on va le faire et après des jours on va
faire un autre test pour voir si tout va
bien ou pas ce très nécessaire c'est une
question de vie ça va
d'autres pays ont suspendu les liaisons
vers et depuis l'inde ou le variant est
jugé particulièrement virulent il ya eu
plus de 2600 morts en 24 heures les
hôpitaux indiens sont débordés par
l'afflux de patients il manque
cruellement de bouteilles d'oxygène mais
aussi de traitement anti qu'ovide cette
situation a obligé le pays à faire appel
à l'armée pour ravitailler les hôpitaux
clis j'ai un message pour le
gouvernement
s'il vous plaît faites quelque chose
libéré un peu d'oxygène
les gens en ont besoin ici les gens ont
besoin de lits de salles d'injection et
de médicaments nous sommes venus ici
avec notre père juste ici mais personne
n'est venu le voir il a juste crié
regardez moi regardez moi mais personne
n'est venu et il est mort
maintenant je suis venu avec mon
grand-père et personne ne le voit
en indonésie les dirigeants des pays de
l'association des nations de l'asie du
sud-est laissent eux n étaient réunis à
jakarta ils sont visiblement sur la même
longueur d'onde il appelle à la fin des
violences et au retour de la démocratie
en birmanie un sommet en présence du
général qui a pris pouvoir à rangoun le
1er février dernier
depuis le pays connaît des
manifestations et aussi une vive
répression qui a fait déjà plusieurs
centaines de morts
on soit ischémique
à l'issue de ce sommet spécial qui aura
duré un peu plus de deux heures
le président indonésien joe cole we do
do prend la parole et met les choses au
point
la situation actuelle est inacceptable
et ne peut plus durer
la violence doit cesser
la stabilité et la paix en birmanie
doivent être restaurés et les tasses
d'entamer un débat l'icann les
prisonniers politiques doivent être
libérés immédiatement et il est
important de nommer des envoyés spéciaux
de la zenn composée du secrétaire
général et du président de la zenn afin
d'encourager le dialogue avec toutes les
parties concernées en birmanie des
déclarations fermes reçu avec
enthousiasme par le gouvernement fantôme
birman mis en place par l'opposition
nous accueillons avec encouragement le
fait que les dirigeants de l'az et anne
et trouver un consensus pour dire que
les violences militaire en birmanie
doivent cesser et que les prisonniers
politiques doivent être libérés
c'est ce que le gouvernement d'unité
nationale a toujours appelé nous sommes
impatients de voir la réalisation des
décisions prises par l'asian et ainsi
restaurer notre démocratie et notre
liberté pour notre peuple et la région
un sommet de jakarta en présence du
leader de la junte le général min aung
kyi a suscité la contestation des
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme depuis le 1er février date du
renversement du gouvernement civil
d'hansson sushis les manifestations et
la répression des militaires ne
connaissent pas de répit
le bilan est lourd plus de 700 personnes
ont été tuées et plusieurs milliers
d'autres arrêtés selon l'association
d'assistance aux prisonniers politiques
des manifestations qui se poursuivent en
birmanie
tout comme la répression un manifestant
a été tué ce samedi à sa sortie du
sommet le chef de la junte birmane n'a
pas fait de déclaration mais il s'est
montré à l'écouté selon les dires du
premier ministre malaisien
il a accepté de recevoir un envoyé de
l'asian pour visiter la birmanie à un
moment approprié ou un moment convenable
il ne s'est pas opposé à cela
cela donne une opportunité à l'asian de
jouer un rôle clé pour aider à résoudre
la crise la malaisie directement
impactée par la situation son pays
voisins au total depuis le début de la
crise près de 200000 birmans ont trouvé
refuge dans le pays
[Applaudissements]
le premier ministre israélien benyamin
nétanyahou appel au calme après les
accrochages à jérusalem où les violences
ont commencé lorsque la police
israélienne a empêché des palestiniens
de se rassembler près de la porte de
damas un lieu symbolique près duquel se
sont rassemblés des juifs de droite
radicale une provocation pour les
palestiniens la police anti-émeute a été
déployée une centaine
blessés sont à déplorer ces violences
qui dure depuis près d'une semaine sont
inédites depuis des années dans la ville
sainte hélène masculi à l'entrée de la
vieille ville de jérusalem
la porte de damas s'embrase cette vague
de violence a débuté la semaine dernière
lors de la première nuit du ramadan
traditionnellement des milliers de
palestiniens viennent s'asseoir sur les
marches au sortir de la prière nocturne
mais cette année la police israélienne
les en a jusqu'à présent empêché depuis
lors des affrontements ont lieu chaque
nuit entre palestiniens et forces de
l'ordre aux abords de ce lieu
emblématique de jérusalem est
jeudi soir les affrontements ont pris
une tournure inédite quand le leader
d'un groupe j suprémacistes a appelé à
un rassemblement pour restaurer le
contrôle des juifs sur le quartier
la manifestation perçue comme une
provocation par les palestiniens a vite
dégénéré en de violents affrontements la
confrontation avec les forces de l'ordre
venues disperser la foule à coups de
canons à eau et de grenades
assourdissantes a fait plus de 120
blessés
ce vendredi encore des violences ont
éclaté dans la vieille ville et ailleurs
renforçant un peu plus les tensions
intercommunautaires
des centaines de palestiniens se sont
rassemblés au point de passage reliant
israël et la cisjordanie
provoquant notamment des incendies une
autre manifestation elle a eu lieu à
ramallah siège de l'autorité
palestinienne
son président mahmoud abbas pointe du
doigt la responsabilité de tel aviv le
gouvernement israélien est pleinement
responsable de cette grave détérioration
les colons et les groupes d'extrême
droite incite à tuer des arabes avec la
protection de l'armée et de la police
israélienne jérusalem est est la
capitale de l'état palestinien
et c'est une ligne rouge de son côté le
maire de jérusalem affirme être en
discussion avec des leaders palestiniens
dans l'espoir d'un retour au calme
nous devons mettre fin à cette situation
je dialogue avec des représentants des
quartiers arabes
nous parlons avec toutes les personnes
pour arrêter ces violences inutiles
nous discutons avec des modérés des deux
côtés pour qu'ils influencent les
extrémistes
des violences qui interviennent à moins
d'un mois des élections législatives
palestiniennes
les premières depuis 15 ans la branche
armée du hamas au pouvoir dans la bande
de gaza met en garde israël
sachez que devant vous se tient une
résistance solide et prête à en découdre
l'étincelle que vous allumez aujourd'hui
sera la mèche de l'explosion à venir une
tension au plus haut et pour l'heure
aucun signe d'apaisement
tard dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
au moins trente six roquettes ont été
lancées de la bande de gaza vers israël
selon tsahal en représailles des chars
de l'armée israélienne et des
hélicoptères sont venus frapper l
enclave palestinienne
retour en france avec les médias et
emmanuel macron les liens du président
avec ces derniers sont assez difficiles
à cerner tantôt critique avec les
journalistes tantôt conciliant là
essayer d'y voir plus clair c'est thomas
bonnet qui nous en dit plus regardé
l'arrivée d'un jeune président a à
l'elysée sa volonté de trancher avec
l'ancien monde a pu donner de l'espoir à
certains en finir avec la connivence
avec la presse
et ravivé l'indépendance des médias
quatre ans plus tard le constat est amer
les relations entre emmanuel macron et
une presse qui l'accusent de jeu si tu
ne plus chercher la vérité se sont
nettement détériorées en tentant d'abord
de délocaliser la salle de presse de
l'elysée puis en ne conviant pas les
journalistes à couvrir certains de ses
déplacements
le président a instauré une distance
avec la profession des journalistes ont
aussi été convoqués par la dgs y ait une
perquisition dans les locaux de
mediapart a même été ordonnée par le
parquet on peut aussi parler de
l'accrochage entre emmanuel macron et le
journaliste du figaro georges malbrunot
lors d'un voyage au liban un échange
capturé à l'époque par les caméras y sur
lequel revient à emmanuel macron lors de
la conférence de presse qui suit et je
vous remercie de parler des sanctions
j'en avais parlé la dernière fois ce qui
n'a pas empêché certains d'entre vous
décrire les pires bêtises sur le sujet
sans vérification aucune
donc j'invite quand vous avez des
questions sur le sujet me les poser
directement
ça facilitera les choses et parce que ce
sont des sujets graves et quand le
locataire de l'elysée
agne finalement recevoir des
journalistes au palais la conversation
prend la forme d'un serment comme relaté
dans un article du point emmanuel macron
il y avait déclaré ses ambitions pour la
presse le bien public
c'est l'information et peut-être que
c'est ce que l'état doit financer le
bien public
ce n'est pas le cameraman de france 3 le
c'est l'information sur bfm sur lci sur
tf1 est partout il faut s'assurer
qu'elle est neutre financer des
structures qui assurent la neutralité
une volonté de mainmise sur les médias
qui a de quoi inquiéter alors que l'état
verse déjà des centaines de millions
chaque année de subventions pour la
presse selon les faits rapportés dans
une enquête du journal le monde le
président agir est aussi en coulisses
pour je cite demandé à son entourage de
passer des appels à certains
propriétaires de journaux voire a
indiqué quels interlocuteurs visés au
sein d'un groupe de presse si jamais il
ya un problème avec un article une
méthode pas très nouveau monde
il n'y a pas que les coups de fils du
président qui inquiète certains se sont
émus récemment de la nomination de cyril
grazziani à la tête du service politique
de france télévisions cet ancien de
france inter est connu pour sa proximité
avec emmanuel macron c'est d'ailleurs
aussi le cas de marc olivier fogiel
directeur général de bfm tv depuis 2019
ou encore de florian dumez cofondateur
des jeunes avec macron est nommé
récemment directeur des relations avec
les pouvoirs publics
chez france télévisions toujours selon
la même enquête du monde emmanuel macron
serait un observateur avisé du secteur
des médias et dans ce paysage médiatique
un acteur inquiète elysées c'est vincent
bolloré la ligne éditoriale de ces news
donnerait des frissons à la ma chronique
qui verrait d'un mauvais oeil l'appétit
du milliardaire les auteurs de l'
enquête du monde nous explique ainsi les
manoeuvres en coulisses entre emmanuel
macron et d'autres grandes fortunes tels
que xavier niel et bernard arnault pour
tenter de contrer l'influencé croissante
de bolloré la preuve que même si les
tient à bonne distance
emmanuel macron c'est qu'une campagne
présidentielle se gagne aussi dans les
médias c'est la fin de ce journal merci
à vous de l'avoir suivi prochain point
sur l'actualité dans une trentaine de
minutes tout à l'heure
[Musique]
la crise du coït 19 à semble-t-il mise
en lumière lippert mondialisation et les
contraintes qui vont avec
démondialiser pas sur un coup de
baguette magique ça coûte cher de
relocaliser il faut aussi changer ce
pourquoi les entreprises sont partis il
ya de grandes passions de le voir et qui
implique des stratégies qui sont
complètement différents vous pouvez
essayer de refaire venir 2